that's exciting that physics might be
able to find equations that unlock our
Origins you can't get meaning you know
from just knowing facts like Wikipedia
knows more than all of us will ever know
right and by the way do you know what
we're our real name is homo sapien
sapien so it's man who knows that he
knows do you know what he knows do you
know what the knowing is it's that he's
gonna die we're the only creatures that
know that we are gonna die we don't know
when we're gonna die the survivalists
think this much is fundamentally
different from like the knowledge of
death whether Ernest Becker comes in
with the terror of death that means a
gift of knowing our own mortality